Doutor, qual é o melhor horário para
tomar glutamina e se pode ser associado
à creatina? Bem, a glutamina não tem um
período assim restrito de uso. Ela pode
ser tomada em vários horários e cada
horário pode ter um benefício
específico, né? Então, além disso, você
pode tranquilamente associar a glutamina
creatina, não tem nenhum problema, pelo
contrário, vai ajudar, tá? Então, quais
são os horários que você pode pensar em
utilizar? Quais seriam os melhores
horários para tomar glutamina? Tem
pessoas que preferem tomar em jejum ao
acordar porque teria a maior absorção de
vitaminas e minerais no organismo.
Poderia funcionar como reforço
imunológico. De fato, a glutamina tem
esse efeito de melhorar o sistema imune.
Para quem faz o jejum intermitente, a
glutamina quebra sim o jejum. Então ela
deve ser consumida no momento que você
quebra esse jejum com outros alimentos,
tá? Um outro horário também muito
popular para usar glutamina é antes do
treino. E a vantagem de usar nesse
horário seria aumentar a liberação de
glutamato,
gerando mais energia paraa atividade
física e ajudando a prevenir a a
degradação muscular. Outro horário
também popular é após o treino. Nesse
horário poderia ter a vantagem de
estimular a recuperação muscular,
acelerar o ganho de massa e aumentar a
produção natural do hormônico
crescimento, né, o chamado GH. Tem
também o horário de antes de dormir.
Nesse horário pode ter a vantagem de
melhorar a nutrição para quem busca
ganho mais substancial de massa
muscular, porque ele aumenta a produção
de GH durante o sono. Então, para esses
casos de tomar a noite, o ideal seria
utilizar antes de deitar pro fechamento
da permeibilidade intestinal. Também tem
o horário de tomar entre as refeições,
que poderia auxiliar na manutenção da
saúde intestinal e do suporte imune,
especialmente em períodos de estresse
físico ou mental.
Então, associe sim a glutamina creatina.
Você vai ter boas respostas com isso.
Não tem nenhum problema, nenhuma
contraindicação de fazer essa
associação. Essa combinação é segura
quando tomada nas doses adequadas e
oferece benefícios complementares. Quais
seriam então esses benefícios
complementares? aceleração da
recuperação muscular, melhora da
hipertrofia, aumentar energia no treino.
A glutamina economiza leucina, que é um
aminoácido que estimula o ganho de massa
muscular, e a creatina faz ressíntese do
ATP, aumentando energia na atividade
física. Quais são os horários então para
tomar junto? Ao acordar, você pode tomar
glutamina com creatina misturada com
água logo de manhã cedo, após o treino.
Aí você pode combinar em batida, né, de
proteínas pós treino durante o dia, pode
ser tomado em outros momentos, pois a
creatina é um suplemento de carga que
exige uso contínuo. Então é muito
flexível os horários que você pode
utilizar tanto um quanto o outro e não
vai ter tanta diferença assim, no meu
ponto de vista, o horário que você toma,
ok? E quais são as duas ágens
recomendadas? A glutamina é de 5 a 10 g
ao dia. Você pode dividir em duas doses
manhã e noite. A creatina entre 3 a 4 g
por dia. Ou você pode fazer a conta de
01 g por kg de peso corporal. Ok? Boa
sorte para você. Compartilhe os vídeos,
faça bem. A vida de alguém pode mudar
também no canal do além do se envolva.
Ah.